obviously you know i'm a huge fan of the
boys
i know you guys have been filming um
where are you in the filming process
uh so i am in toronto um
we are almost we are
almost halfway through uh filming season
three i mean
uh we're we're like let's say
between one fourth of the way through
and halfway through that's where we're
at um
and uh i can't say much but i will say
that this season
is grounded uh a lot more
in story um
and and i think more so than the last
two seasons
you know like eric crickey i think what
he's doing is every season he's getting
darker and darker and with the addition
of jensen ackles
um that allowed him to not only
bring in a character historically who's
pretty dark
but it also makes all of the other
ensemble soups
darker as well so yeah i i'm curious
though
um the first two seasons have definitely
amped up like the first season had blood
the second season had a lot of blood
um how would you compare is one of the
is this season as bloody as the others
or is it
different uh
so i'll put it to you this way i was
talking to the makeup
um uh the head makeup artist
and she's in charge of ordering the
blood
that's that's her job one of her many
jobs
sure she told me that
all of season two you remember how much
blood there was in season two
i vividly i don't think they used
um when you when you talk about bulk
i don't think they used over a gallon of
blood
in season two believe it or not uh
season three we're already at three and
a half gallons
of blood so
that should give you a little indication
of where
it's going uh i am curious though how
has
uh kovid impacted the filming process
is it um is it could you sort of talk
about how how does that affect
production
we've been very lucky man i mean we
knock on wood
uh have not had any cases um in our
immediate a cast and crew
area we have not
had any stoppages we get tested every
single day we have to wear our masks
constantly whether it's at base camp or
on set everyone has to wear them indoor
or outdoors
uh just to follow the canadian protocol
mandates
and so uh they they and then even like
on your days off you still get tested
in the event that something were to
happen or someone
gets sick and they have to
re-pull up scenes or reorganize scenes
they want to make sure that everyone is
tested
and able to work in the event that an
emergency were to happen so
they've pretty much crossed every t and
dotted every eye
and uh we've been lucky because up until
now
we haven't had any any problems this
season as compared to the others
does eric pull you aside and like tell
you the whole arc
or are you finding it out like script by
script so
in the beginning of the season i don't
know if he does this with all of the
actors but in the beginning of the
season
he and i do talk about mother's milk's
journey
just so that i have an idea of how to
craft
where i am and where i'm going um and
how to build that slowly
um and this season i find that
because he hasn't been here because of
covid you know when you come you got to
do a mandatory 14-day quarantine and
that his ability to come in and out has
been severely hindered
because of all of the other stuff um
uh it's been a lot more emails
and text messages and i mean listen at
all hours
you know like it could be 11 o'clock at
night
and he'll hit me and i'll respond at
like
seven in the morning eastern time and
he'll hit me right back i'm like man
did he ever sleep you know so um
it's it's it's extremely collaborative
uh and uh you still feel his presence
you
you feel that he's got his finger on the
pulse of everything that's going on
um so it's fine
it's good